j'ai décidé de briser la loi du silence
d'abord pour ne pas mourir pour que la
vérité soit connue
[Musique]
il a sorti son sexe a pris m'obliger à
me mettre à genoux qu'après je peux pas
dire louis vuitton pénibles a évidemment
fait de revoir ces images à faire
remonter tout tout ce qui s'est passé
c'est violent est ce que quand on voit
le parcours de la combattante que j'ai
menées pour faire entendre la vérité et
catherine affirme aussi que tout au long
du stage elle aurait tenté d'alerter
l'entraîneur de l'équipe de france mais
en vain un entraîneur qui nie les faits
tout comme les quatre athlètes ce
inculpé
et en fait pour toute réponse il a eu
sept
cette phrase on me disant ma petite
fille vous êtes jeune vous oublierez
j'ai même des menaces de mort pour
retirer ma plainte mais en fait c'était
un long combat parce que tout était tout
a été fait pour justement empêcher que
la vérité ne se soit exprimé
et au final la justice a reconnu ces
agressions
en appel les peines ont été aggravées et
la responsabilité de l'état pour la
première fois dans l'histoire a été
reconnue a été relevé par la justice
française j'ai été complètement mise à
l'écart par les institutions sportives
françaises et j'avais interdiction de
retourner m'entraîner à l'institut
national des sports
ce sont des injustices qui se rajoute
aux injustices déjà accumulés
dans cette histoire moi je demande
qu'est ce que je deviens parce que
encore une fois c'est quand même moi la
victime
alors qu'on essaie de me traiter comme
une coupable comme une pestiférée pour
une brebis galeuses et je rappelle quand
même que je n'ai pas demandé à être
violée en stage national
tout a été fait tout a été dit et rien
n'a été exprimée est décidée au plus
haut niveau de l'état pour que ces
violences quelle qu'elle soit 16,6
j'ai réalisé au fil du temps au fil de
mon combat que ça n'était pas arrivé
simplement à catherine moyen de bach
mais à beaucoup d'autres avant et j'ai
voulu parler puisque je pouvais le faire
pour toutes celles qui n'avaient pas le
courage ou pas la force pour toutes
celles qui ne n'osais pas il s'agit ici
de la fédération française de patinage
de sport des glaces mais tous les sports
sont concernés plus ou moins par ces
violences quelles que soient les
violences
[Musique]